hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
I'm a property investor and in this
video I'm going to be explaining what is
a bridging loan and how to finance
properties via bridging finance so stay
tuned and please do hit that like button
and subscribe if you haven't already
[Music]
guys I really appreciate all your
comments questions feedback interaction
on this channel one of the things has
been coming up quite a lot is people
been asking what's a bridging loan
listen if you don't know what a bridging
loan is that's no problem all I'm
explaining this video but it's not going
to magically mean that you can buy loads
of houses for free okay
the thing that you need to do the number
one thing is always being able to find
good deals if you bring me the right
deals I'll believe me we can find that
answer for it you can buy a house
without using any of your own money as
long as you can find the right deals you
can however bridging bridging finance is
just a tool in a toolbox that is going
to help you finance deals and recycle
your money which means that if you've
got to pay fifty thousand pounds twenty
thousand pounds you can buy not just one
house but you can buy again and again
and again and again and again you can
keep buying houses using bridging
finance so what is bridging finance a
bridging loan or bridging finance is
when you will be lent money so someone
will lend you money they'll usually
charge a lot of interest it can be
anywhere between usually like 10 and 20
percent which is a lot the banks high
street lenders that will give you a
mortgage on a house you talking like
three four five percent so 10 to 20
percent it's a lot of interest what does
that mean does that mean that you're
going to end up paying a lot no because
you're gonna have it for a short period
of time let's say you find a house I'll
give an example and the house the value
is 100 thousand pound and it needs about
twenty thousand pound spending on it and
when you spend twenty thousand pound on
it and it's really pretty it might be
worth a hundred and forty thousand pound
let's say that's the situation but you
managed to knock them down and you get
it in a real bargain because you find a
motivated seller and you're not a
motivated buyer
meet a few people and you buy it for
80,000 pounds but you tell them you're
gonna buy it cash so I'm gonna buy the
house cash for 80,000 pound now having
access to bridging finance means that
you can talk and have the confidence and
posture of a cash buyer without being a
cash buyer because you have access to
the cash so you say oh by 80 grams but I
like cash and you can put forward cheeky
offers when you were touched by because
you buy it cash the bridging finance a
lending company if you've got bad credit
they don't care if you have got issues
or you don't own any houses currently or
they don't care they only care about one
thing the bridging lenders care that you
can find these types of good deals why
because when you buy the house and they
lend you the money they'll have a charge
on the property they'll be able to see
this house is a good house you're
running a business
they don't care about you okay Matt your
family better care about your job I care
about your income but I can't make your
credit take care about the house that
your mind as long as you let them have a
charge on the house which means that if
you don't pay their money back then
they're gonna have the house so they'll
buy the house they'll put the money in
and normally you'll need to put down a
small amount of the money which you can
do or you can borrow for someone house a
bridging lender doesn't care where
you've got your deposit from within
reason okay if you borrowed it from an
investor that's okay you buy his house
for 80 grand you say you're gonna bite
cash they say yes then you're like holy
crap what or do you borrow the money i
keeping borrowing a little bit from a
friend or you can put a little bit down
yourself but you borrow the majority of
the money from the bridging lender you
then buy it for 80,000 you then spend
the 20 grands with money more money from
the bridging company there our company
are bridging companies out there that
will give you 100% of the development or
refurb for the property now you've got
this house but you are bought in cash
most of its from the bridging company if
you've done a refurb on it with the
bridging company's money now your job is
now to get a new mortgage on the
property which will be a normal buy to
let mortgage or what whatever whatever
kind of mortgage
you'll borrow the money
another mortgage company but this time
you won't pay 10 20 percent you'll pay 3
percent you'll borrow the money on the
house and the money that you borrow for
the house you'll then use that to pay
off the bridging company which means
that your interest payments will drop
massively very quickly you can get a new
mortgage on the house straightaway there
used to be a six-month for all that said
you have to wait six months but after
buying your house before you can
refinance but now you can do it with
this companies like Kent Reliance
they'll give you a mortgage straight
away as soon as the proper soon as that
value is lifted on the house that's the
essence of what a bridging loan is so if
you can find good deals you can find
houses whereby you can add value and
then increase the value then bridging
finance could be fantastic
for you but if you can't find the deals
you don't you don't borrow money on a
bridging loan to buy a rubbish house
that's just gonna burn you be very very
careful that's what on my crash course I
teach strategies that are very very safe
we start with basic buy two lap we then
move on to more advanced strategies so
please before you buy a house get the
training car aren't my crash course it
is free it's on me okay there are
opportunities to do advanced training
but the crash course is free also speak
to mortgage brokers speak to bridging
finance companies make sure that when
you make a decision you know you are
well informed and I'm happy to give you
all the information to do that just get
yourself down to the crash course I'll
share
you'll meet a whole bunch of people I
hope you found that useful and get asked
the question a lot so I hope I explained
it okay if you like my videos subscribe
I'd be really grateful if you could
subscribe and don't forget to share this
video smash that like button and stay
tuned for next for the next video real
soon
I see tomorrow
[Music]
you